اين ومتى وكيف كل هذا في حسابات كييف
يتحفظ الاوكرانيون على الهجوم المضاد لكن
ثمه مؤشرات عليه وفق مسؤولين امريكيين
بحسب صحيفه نيويورك تايمز صحيح انك لم
تعلن رسميا عن بدء العمليات غير ان هجمات
كبيره عملت معها روسيا في منطقه
وعلى ذمه الصحيفه فان المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين لم يبلغوا نظرائهم الامريكيين
متى ستبدا المعارك لكنهم قدموا اطارا
زمنيا وهو اطار على ما يبدو يقترب من بدء
الهجوم المضاد او هجوم مضاد جزئيا وفق
ترجيحات مسؤولين امريكيين ترجيحات استندت
الى معلومات من الاقمار الصناعيه العسكريه
الامريكيه رصدت زياده في الحركه من
المواقع العسكريه الاوكرانيه
معطيات تشير الى ان حمله اوكرانيه اوليه
بدات لتحديد مواقع القوات الروسيه وفق ما
يراه محللون عسكريون امريكيون وهو تكتيك
تقليدي كان الامريكيون يدربون القوات
الاوكرانيه على استخدامه
المسؤولون الغربيون يرجحون ان الهجوم
المضاد سيركز على جنوب اوكرانيا كجزء من
استراتيجيه لقطع الجسر البري بين غربي
روسيا وشبه جزيره القرم
واذا تمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه من احداث
اختراق في منطقه نوفو دونيتسك ستتمكن
في جنوب اوكرانيا وقتل الاتصالات بين
المدينه
الخاضعتين للسيطره الروسيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات